[Música]
a depressão e ansiedade
duas das coisas que são reputados como
sendo talvez os principais males da vida
moderna
o brasil é um dos países mais deprimidos
e mais ansiosos do mundo
alguns se apressam em apontar a
tecnologia como responsável por esse
estado de coisas
eu pessoalmente até concordo mas a
tecnologia não é a principal vilã a
tecnologia acelera as coisas do meu
jeito que meu coração está acelerado
agora a tecnologia faz com que nós nos
sintamos todos os dias soterrados por
uma avalanche de informação de estímulos
isso é uma coisa extremamente complicada
de se administrar mas eu tenho a crer
que a principal razão pela qual todos
nós nos sentimos tão ansiosos e muitas
vezes deprimidos tem a ver com uma
percepção equivocada a respeito da nossa
idéia como sociedade a respeito do que é
sucesso muito mais comumente do que
seria desejável
a gente vê a idéia de sucesso associada
à idéia de dinheiro
quanto mais dinheiro eu tenho mais
sucesso eu tenho eu tenho que trabalhar
muito e eu tenho que ter uma carreira
brilhante eu tenho que fazer cursos
eu tenho que buscar de todas as formas
ser o melhor profissional que eu puder
para que eu possa ganhar tanto dinheiro
quanto possível
como se isso não bastasse essa mesma
sociedade que foi construída em torno de
idéias de consumo de sucesso
atrelado a um material tão bem nos
obriga a sermos
perfeitos e perfeitas em outros aspectos
da nossa vida nos obriga a sermos pais e
mães prefeitos e prefeitas nos obriga
encontrarmos tempo para cuidarmos da
nossa saúde para irmos à academia para
sermos uma olhada um bombadão a malhador
na bomba do na sala dona nos obriga a
ter tempo para sermos perfeitos no trato
com os nossos familiares nos obriga a
ter tempo para o convívio social nos
obriga a encontrar maneiras para sermos
aquela família do comercial de margarina
para colocar o filho ea filha na cama
para contar uma história e se possível
ter ânimo e disposição para uma noite de
sexo selvagem e de preferência que se
repita quando acordamos essa idéia de
perfeição não existe mas nós raramente
nos damos conta disso nós passamos a
vida perseguindo isso e isso pra mim é a
grande causa do excesso de ansiedade e
da quantidade de pessoas deprimidas no
mundo hoje
talvez alguns de vocês em algum momento
das nossas histórias tenham passado por
isso estudos mostram que cerca de 90%
das pessoas pelo menos uma vez ao dia se
sente ansioso e se sentia ansiosa
eu sei bem do que estou falando
a história que eu quero compartilhar com
vocês falam um pouco a esse respeito
eu vim de família humilde nasceu no rio
de janeiro cresci numa rua sem asfalto
com esgoto correndo a céu aberto na
baixada fluminense à região do rio que
naquela época a região mais violenta da
cidade e do estado
desde muito cedo na vida eu coloquei na
minha cabeça que eu ia vencer na vida e
desde muito cedo na vida venceu a vida
pra mim significava uma coisa dinheiro e
eu passei a maior parte da minha vida
correndo atrás disso
estudei muito trabalhei muito tive uma
carreira que se desenvolveu super
rapidamente aos 40 anos que tinha
conquistado maior parte das coisas que a
maioria das pessoas associa com sucesso
eu tinha uma posição de destaque numa
grande empresa eu tinha um carro com
motorista
eu tinha duas secretárias
uma moto e um carro importados eu
viajava nos lugares mais distantes do
mundo nas minhas férias eu tinha
condições de fazer tudo aquilo que
tipicamente é associado com sucesso
mas eu sentia que alguma coisa da
faltava que pedir demissão do emprego
foi trabalhar numa outra grande empresa
agora no setor financeiro e quando tomei
essa decisão
fui a três vezes mais do que ganhava no
emprego anterior
agora eu tinha certeza nada mais lhe
faltaria porque afinal de contas eu
teria mais dinheiro do que jamais tinha
tido em toda a minha vida me mudo de
curitiba vai morar numa cidade distante
deixo minha família meu filho por aqui e
quando chego lá
percebo que continua faltando alguma
coisa
um belo dia a chegar em casa no final da
tarde um apartamento que morava deixando
o meu super carro importado na garagem
abrindo uma garrafa de um super vinho
daqueles bem caros esnobes eu recebi uma
ligação da minha esposa época me
relatando um problema do meu filho na
escola
meu filho lucca na época tinha de 11
para 12 anos
o problema com o filho na escola com
nota algo trivial
a maioria daqueles que são pais e mães
em algum momento já passaram por isso
pra mim não seria tão trivial porque
aquilo disparou o gatilho que me fez
lembrar de uma história que se passaram
alguns anos atrás
mais especificamente no ano de 2002
quando a minha esposa à época fica
grávida do meu filho eu naquela época
imbuído da idéia de ter sucesso à base
de sacrificar aquilo que precisasse para
que eu pudesse ganhar mais dinheiro
eu tinha o sonho de fazer um mba e fora
do país
apliquei para uma bolsa do conselho
britânico para estudar na inglaterra e
achei que a bolsa não sairia viagem com
minha esposa época de férias ela volta
grávida e quando nós voltamos com a
notícia da gravidez
a bolsa sair e eu me vi diante de uma
escolha viajar para a inglaterra
passar um ano fazendo mestrado e deixar
meu filho recém-nascido ou abrir mão
daquela escolha profissional vai ficar
com meu filho eu fui pra inglaterra em
vários momentos da história do lucca
eu estava distante eu não vi a primeira
engatinhado eu não assisti ao primeiro
balbuciar eu não troquei as primeiras
fraldas
eu não vi a primeira vez que ele foi ao
banheiro
eu simplesmente não vê naquele momento
em que se repete de alguma maneira
aquela situação em que meu filho está
diante de uma situação de uma
necessidade e que eu não estou lá pra tá
do lado dele
a única coisa que eu consegui fazer
naquele momento foi chorar muito
copiosamente como que expurgando todos
os meus demônios e naquele momento eu me
tornei personagem de revista porque eu
pedi demissão daquele super emprego
retornei para curitiba
fui parar em revistas sites como o
brasileiro que abre mão do emprego de
900 mil reais para empreender volta para
curitiba disposto a nunca mais passar
por aquilo e resolvo que você
empreendedor
eu tinha certeza que seria a coisa mais
fácil do mundo afinal de contas eu tinha
um diploma de mestrado da fgv na parede
eu tinha um diploma de mestrado na
inglaterra eu tinha um diploma de
harvard eu era a mp da turma 179 da
harvard business school e empreender
seria fácil seria como brincadeira de
criança
o segundo semestre de 2013 foi o
semestre mais terrível da minha vida
porque eu não tinha a menor idéia do que
elas empreendedor e pior ainda eu
continuava motivado sem perceber pelas
mesmas motivações que me motivaram até
então eu comecei a pensar em criar
negócios que me deixassem rico mas é um
negócio onde está o dinheiro em isso que
eu vou fazer é isso que eu quero porque
afinal de contas sucesso continua sendo
a possibilidade de se encher de dinheiro
5 de dezembro de 2013
eu estava diagnosticado com síndrome de
burnout painel teu nome chique que os
psicólogos e profissionais de saúde dão
para dizer pra você que você surto
basicamente era o que estava acontecendo
comigo eu entro na internet e vi uma
passagem para o nepal porque nepal
simples porque ninguém vai ler paulo foi
o lugar mais distante que eu consegui
imaginar porque tudo que eu queria
naquele momento era sumir do mundo
eu queria ir para um lugar onde ninguém
o encontrasse onde eu não tivesse
referências de onde eu pudesse de alguma
maneira entender o que estava
acontecendo se tudo na minha vida tem
aquele momento havia sido construído em
torno da hipótese da idéia de ter
sucesso baseado em dinheiro por que
razão por que diabos eu não estava feliz
se eu tinha arrumado um emprego que me
pagava 1 milhão de reais por ano
chegando em katmandu
eu fui a um monastério budista chamado
monastério de copán uma série de
campanha maior mas é budista da ásia
fica nas montanhas no entorno de
katmandu
eu fiquei lá por uma semana vivendo uma
vida monástica convivendo com os monges
na chegada ao monastério eu passei uma
lojinha que havia aumentado no
monastério comprei dois cadernos nesses
cadernos sem nenhuma conexão com a
internet sem computador sem celular eu
escrever num dos cadernos tentativa de
encontrar respostas para todas as
perguntas que eu não tinha
no segundo caderno
eu escrevi o meu obituário hoje em 12 de
maio de 2000 e setembro e 2 morreu allan
costa até aquele momento 40 anos eu
sabia qual era a história que esse
obituário pontaria
daquele momento em diante eu não tinha a
menor idéia
eu tive que escrever a história da minha
vida e quando voltei de lá voltei com
algumas lições que balizam todas as
minhas escolhas e tudo que eu faço na
minha vida desde então
ao longo dos últimos seis anos eu me
tornei palestrante viajar o brasil
inteiro fazendo palestra me tornei
empresário criei negócios mais
fundamentalmente eu me tornei uma pessoa
cujo maior prazer na vida é compartilhar
as próprias experiências para que quem
sabe mais pessoas possam aproveitar de
alguma maneira algumas daquelas poucas
opções que eu tenho aprendido ao longo
da vida eu quero compartilhar com vocês
três breves descrições
a primeira delas aqui para sair desse
estado de torpor em que a maioria de nós
nos encontramos perseguindo essa idéia
de sociedade perfeita
nós precisamos fazer o que eu chamo de
desligar o piloto automático
nós vivemos um permanente estado de
piloto automático
numa quase que síndrome de zeca
pagodinho deixa a vida me levar vida
leva eu
a gente passa pela vida sem se
questionar sem parar para pensar se o
caminho que a gente está seguindo é
aquele que nós queremos e o que é mais
triste na maioria das vezes nós não
sabemos qual é o caminho que nós
queremos pensem com vocês por um segundo
qual foi a última vez que você se
permitiu tirar um único dia da sua vida
um mísero dia para dedicar este único
singelo dia única e exclusivamente a
pensar na coisa mais importante que você
tem que a sua própria vida
nós não fazemos isso e ao não fazer isso
entramos nesse estado de piloto
automático
a segunda coisa que eu aprendi reside na
beleza das trilhas - percorridos eu sou
motociclista viajo por trilhas países
estradas andando de moto e uma das
coisas que eu aprendi ao longo das
minhas viagens é que as melhores
paisagens jamais se revelam
para quem se contenta em percorrer as
trilhas mais percorridas em determinados
momentos da vida é preciso se atirar
antes de chegar nessa palestra excited
eu passei quase uma semana preparando
slides
mas eu achei que seria absolutamente
incoerente com o que eu estou tentando
comunicar vir aqui me falar
lá pra vocês trilhas - percorridas
apoiado num conjunto de slides nessa
televisão
eu deixei os slides a cargo dos meus
amigos que estão controlando a mesa de
som e resolvi seguir uma trilha -
percorrido por que eu acreditei que
assim eu poderia compartilhar com maior
verdade aquilo que eu acredito escolha
trilhas - percorridas ea terceira coisa
que eu quero compartilhar com vocês é a
necessidade premente de que todos nós
adquirimos consciência quanto a uma das
maiores armadilhas as quais somos
submetidos tem uma boa olhada na cadeira
que vocês estão sentados e sentadas
nesse exato momento se encontram
confortáveis não se encontram
eu tenho nesse momento duas certezas a
primeira é que se você é muito grande
você estar desconfortável nessa cadeira
a segunda é que se você for pequeno
pequena você está escorregando nessa
cadeia porque eu tenho essa certeza
porque essas cadeiras foram projetadas
para um ser humano médio
nós vamos pegar um carro daqui a pouco
pra casa se for grande tem que pôr banco
atrás se for pequena quem sabe tem que
pôr uma almofada para sentar em cima
porque esse carro foi projetado para um
ser humano médio quando a gente vai a um
restaurante daqueles bem xix superfícies
pessoas como eu grandes e com grande
apetite passam fome
pessoas que comem pouco deixam comida no
prato porque a porção de comida foi
programada para um ser humano médio e
vocês já entenderam com perfeição onde
eu quero chegar
nós vivemos num mundo programado para
funcionar pela média
tudo é feito pela média e sabe qual é a
grande tragédia dessa história é que não
somos colocados nessa armadilha é muito
cedo para nos darmos conta
minha filha mais nova mariana tem dois
anos e meio seu passatempo predileto é
mariana brincando porque quando vejo
mariana brincando entrou em contato com
a essência do ser humano
mariana brinca mariana explora o mundo
em volta
mariana constrói e desconstrói testa diz
testa
mariana não tem idéia de certo e errado
aquilo que pode aquilo que não pode
aquilo que é arriscado aquilo que deixa
de ser arriscado ea ideia daquilo que é
social
mente aceitável simplesmente não existe
na cabecinha de mariana no início desse
ano mariana foi para a escola escolheu
uma escola construtivista para ser menos
careta e quadrada mas ainda assim para
que mariana pudesse entrar no seu
primeiro dia de aula
eu tive que comprar para mariana algo
sem o qual ela não entraria na escola eu
tive que comprar para mariana uniforme o
que faz um uniforme onde for mesa e
mariana quando chegarão uniformizados na
escola vai encontrar pessoas que vão
começar a dizer a ela aquilo que ela
pode aquilo que ela não pode aquilo que
ela deve e aquilo que ela não deve não
confunda isso com limite não é disso que
nós estamos falando
nós estamos falando da castração tela
qual todos nós passamos para que nós nos
acomodaremos a esse modelo de mundo
construído pela média e aí mariana daqui
a pouco vai entrar na escola vai começar
a ter disciplina geografia química
matemática um dia ela pode chegar em
casa e dizer pra mim papai eu adoro
português mas eu odeio matemática eu vou
dizer pela sinto muito querida você vai
estudar tudo isso porque o que tem para
hoje porque o sistema educacional é o
mesmo para todo mundo ele não faz
distinção entre as nossas necessidades
das nossas características individuais e
um dia mariana vai chegar no ensino
médio vai começar a se preocupar cada
vez mais com a tal da média porque ela
precisa de média para passar de ano
porque ela precisa de média para ter
acesso a uma boa faculdade é uma
faculdade que seja pelo menos média por
aquela parte 45 anos da vida dela
fazendo um curso na média para que ela
se forma na média tem um diploma da
média quem sabe consiga um emprego na
média queria é um salário na média uma
carreira na média para que ela compre
uma casa na média um carro na média e
perpetue
esse maldito ciclo vicioso da média
não há maneira de ter uma vida
extraordinária a não ser acordando para
esse estado de coisas
a grande capacidade de realização que
cada um de nós tem não pode estar
vinculada a uma idéia de sucesso
material que preconiza que a realização
é comprar o carro do ano a maior casa
possível obter a maior conta bancária
segredo da realização não está em olhar
para fora sem olhar pra dentro
encontramos as nossas verdades o nosso
propósito e aquilo que verdadeiramente
nos jogos realizados
eu desejo para vocês uma vida com muitas
trilhas não percorridas com o piloto
automático completamente desligado e uma
vida em que vocês sejam capazes de
sempre e todo o tempo estarem
conscientes das vossas escolhas porque
essa é a receita para uma vida de
realização
obrigado
[Aplausos]
[Música]